foreign
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to another
puzzle solving video about a year ago I
did a series of videos in which I solved
a series of exercises on chess.com's
tactic server and I divided these videos
into different levels of puzzles I did a
beginner exercise video I I did a video
in which I solved intermediate level
exercises and then my most viewed video
was the one in which I solved the most
complex Grand Master Level puzzles on
chess.com and the way I Define that were
puzzles uh within the rating range I
believe that video was 27.50 to 3100
which are some of the most complicated
uh and convoluted exercises that you
will find on chess.com and over the last
couple of weeks I've gotten a lot of
requests on my stream to do another one
of these videos in which we do four or
five of these exercises and I walk you
through kind of in a live look at
exactly how I approach these complex
educated exercises what goes through my
mind what variations I calculate and
essentially to give you an expose of how
how a GM tends to approach Master Level
tactics and so I've listened these
videos are super fun to make and so
without further Ado we're gonna do four
or five of these exercises I'm going to
Target about a 35 or 40 minute video
length so hard to say exactly how many
exercises we will solve but as many as
we can in that time and just like in the
previous video if we come across a
particularly complicated exercise I can
reproduce the position on chess space
which will allow me to make moves on the
board that is not for my benefit but if
I can sense that there are five or six
move variations that might be difficult
for you to follow then I will reproduce
the position on chess space but
otherwise I will be using arrows a lot
and I will be speaking in variations
especially if you're newer to chess you
can definitely have a chessboard next to
you and on which you set up these
positions and then make the moves as I'm
saying them but a great way to practice
your calculation would be to really push
yourself to visualize these lines along
with me even if you struggle to do that
that can really help you expand your
ability to visualize long lines which of
course is one of the most if not the
most important skill when it comes to
solving tactical exercises and finding
these tactics during the game so I've
upped the ante even further in this in
this video the rating range now is 2800
to 3200 so it's entirely possible that I
will make a mistake on one of these
exercises and if I do which is totally
normal I don't have a hundred percent
accuracy the point is not to avoid
mistakes it's to understand exactly why
you made them try to use every mistake
as a way to advance uh your
understanding of pattern recognition
and diagnose exactly what went wrong in
the process of solving
so without further Ado here we go in the
first position it is white to move and
the first thing that I always do no
matter what level of difficulty I'm
solving is count the material because
that gives you a general sense of what
it is that you're looking for
so here it seems that material is equal
sort of no black is up two Pawns
no black is actually up three pawns my
goodness so three six seven
and white only has four pawns why does a
queen a knight black as a queen and
Bishop now the second thing that I see
is that Black's Bishop is simply hanging
so King takes G1 is going to be a
candidate move that we should return to
the second big thing that I'm noticing
is that Black's King is caught in the
crossfire of White's Knight and queen
and the Knight and queen is considered
to be the strongest tandem in chess
you've probably come across a bunch of
mating patterns that involve the queen
at night so my guess is that the
solution is either going to involve
taking Black's bishop and then dodging
the checks that Black's Queen is
inevitably going to deliver or there's
some sort of mating construction with
the queen and Knight so let's start by
understanding what happens after King
takes Bishop so if we take the bishop
black is probably going to give that
check on E1 and I'm already pretty
pessimistic about the king's ability to
escape the checks King G2 I see that the
queen can drop back to E4 and if we run
to the H file King H2 there's this nasty
check on H7 and if we drop back to G1
the queen is able to keep pursuing the
king from B1 so there's B1 E4 and H7
depending on where White's King runs it
feels to me King takes q1 results in a
Perpetual so let's set that aside and
let's look at the direct approaches
toward trying to Checkmate Black's King
so what kinds of moves come to mind well
Queen F7 check to me uh is is the most
obvious of the attacking attempts that
forces the king to step back onto the
eighth rank there's King diet and King
C8 what I'm also noticing is that black
is not actually threatening any checks
that's super valuable that's an
important piece of information that
helps us tremendously which tells me
that we can make potentially a quiet
move in order to set up let's say a
mating net so we're getting somewhere
Queen F7 check after King to C8 I think
just such a quiet move forces black to
give up their Queen we can slide Our
Queen over to E7 with the obvious idea
of preparing Knight D6 check King B8 and
then Queen takes B7 or even Queen d8 is
going to be Checkmate as a result so
Queen F7 check King C8 Queen E7 that's a
pretty common mating pattern so looking
around the board to see if black has any
ways to stop that I don't see it Knight
D6 is coming whether black licener likes
it or not and if King B8 then we can
immediately deliver the Checkmate on d8
so black is gonna have to give up his
Queen so after Queen F7 check it seems
like King d8 is the only other defensive
approach and here we can try to set up a
similar mating construction we can
actually capture the pawn on G7 with the
very similar symmetrical idea of Knight
takes E6 check King C8 and then Queen E8
mate and the reason I see this kind of
stuff quickly is just because I'm very
familiar with a lot of the mating
patterns that arise when you have a
queen and Knight right I've just done a
lot of tactics uh on that topic so Queen
F7 check King d8 Knight takes G7 does
black have a way to stop Knight takes E6
check man my aero drawing game is not
particularly Advanced so the one move
that I see there after Queen F7 king T
at Knight takes G7 is actually B6 with
the idea of opening up a Luft Square for
the King on B7 but calculating that line
shows us that white can win the queen
queen F7 Kane d8 Knight takes Pawn B6 we
take on E6 the king slides over to C8 we
deliver the check on E8 which would be
made now the King has B7 but our Knight
is on E6 the black king is on B7 and our
Queen are making contact with each other
which tells me look for a discover check
and just that your discover check exists
98 check
s up the black queen on E5 which is
undefended and that I think is the
solution the key is to avoid taking the
bishop and go directly for Black's King
Let's test this out check Knight takes
G7 and I like to to carry out the
solution quickly as an added layer of
challenge if you're solving exercises
you can absolutely pause on every move
and double check but I hold myself to
the highest standard which means if I
didn't solve the puzzle from the first
move then you know for a Grand Master
that is essentially tantamount to
getting it wrong now you take C6 check
and okay black gives up the queen but
once again the important line is B6 here
Knight takes C6 check King C8 we check
on E8 and then we deliver another check
on d8 and it's also important to
remember that you're not only searching
for checkmate in these types of
positions you're also searching for ways
to exploit the weakness of your
opponent's king in order to pick up a
bunch of materials so I was
simultaneously looking for for mating
construction but I was also looking for
things like discover checks and forks
all right on to the next one
whoa okay so this is a crazy position
white has just captured Our Queen
now just looking at the state of White's
King tells me that this is some sort of
forced mate these puzzles are typically
a lot easier I think I've already gotten
it so first of all the Rook is hanging
the first move seems really obvious it
looks like it has to be 93 check
for sinking E2 and now it appears that
the bishop is gonna have to step away
somewhere in order to set up a mating
net and I just think brute force in
these types of cases is incredibly
effective note that Knight D4 check is
ineffective because that square is
defended by White's Knight so after
Knight E3 King E2 Bishop G1 is a
tempting move because it keeps the
Knight on E3 protected but then the king
drops back to E1
you can take the pawn on C2 with Chuck
but there it looks like we're moving in
the wrong direction because the white
king could potentially even escape to B1
and taking the Rook on A1 is totally
ineffective again white is up a queen so
there's no amount of material that we
could possibly win here that is going to
justify that also our King is
essentially checkmated white threatens
Queen F5 mate so where else can we go
after Knight E3 King E2 we can drop back
to G3 that keeps the E1 Square protected
and after King takes E3 the bishop
slides back to F4 with Checkmate so this
is just all about being familiar with
typical mating Nets and and having a
keen sense of uh mating patterns and
also using process of Illumination so
check check and mate this is just a
maiden three a simple exercise and we
move on to the next one okay so here we
have opposite colored Bishops we have a
middle game with what seems to be equal
material yes seven pawns a piece and you
know the first thing that jumps out at
me and I'm pretty sure this is also what
you're probably seeing is that these two
pieces can be forked by the move d4
now I'm helped by the fact that I've set
the rating range in such a way that I
know that's not the end of the puzzle
and after D4 the next thing that occurs
to me is that white can play Rook a to
D1 that's a very typical way of
indirectly defending against a pawn
capture right you're just pinning the
pawn to the queen so Rook 81 actually
threatens to eliminate the pawn of the
bishop after D4 Rook ad1 testing out the
queen sacrifices really quickly dedc no
that doesn't seem effective uh maybe we
have compensation but we're definitely
not winning what about D4 Rook ad1
Knight takes C3 that also seems
ineffective we're probably going to lose
the D4 Pawn as a result now another move
that is circling circulating around my
mind is the move H5 this is the move
that I saw pretty quickly it dislodges
the queen from G4 and I'm not sure
exactly how it's going to help us but
it's it's worth keeping this move in
mind and testing it out in various
positions we can play it immediately and
then follow up with D4 on the next move
or we can interpose the move order we
can play D4 first Rook 81 and then play
H5 so that seems a little bit more
forcing Let's test out that move order
first so D4 rook ad1 and then H5 so
where can the queen go it can drop back
to E2 it can move over to F4 we have to
basically test every square there's no
you know easier way to do that so after
D4 Rook 81 H5 Queen F4 I think the move
G5 is really strong because the queen is
out of squares which means it has to
take the pawn on G5 but then we're able
to unpin Our Queen by trading queens and
taking on C3 and in the resulting
position a rook on A8 is actually doing
a very important job of defending the d8
square otherwise that would have been
made in one
so that's a promising start D4 Rook 81
H5 so we've refuted Queen F4 what about
Queen back to E2 well the good thing
about that move is that the pawn on D4
now has one less attacker on it so maybe
we could sort of move our Queen in such
a way that unpins it and simultaneously
keeps the D4 Pawn protected and I see
actually two squares that fulfill that
aim Queen to H4 is one possibility and
queen to B6 is the other now there's no
such thing as a two uh two possible
solutions in a chest.com exercise so
there's some sort of catch but Queen B6
looks totally winning to me white can
play A5 there attacking the queen but
the queen has a nice parking spot on B4
and it seems to me that white is
inevitably going to lose a minor piece I
don't see any tactical Shenanigans there
so that's good as well D4 Rook 81 H5 now
there is the H3 Square
and that essentially leads to the same
result where white takes his eyes off of
the D4 Pawn allowing us to shift Our
Queen over let's say to B6
E4 upon protected and reinforcing the
threat in that case only of D takes E3
but if the bishop moves then we can of
course take the Knight because the
bishop will lose its pin on the queen
so again we have to check the move A5
right so D4 Rook ad1 H5 Queen H3 Queen
B6 white tries A5 if we take that pawn
then we lose our control over the D4
Pawn but once again I don't see anything
wrong with Queen before I suppose the
white is Knight A2 in that position but
Queen takes A5 or queen A4 hits the
Knight hits the bishop at the same time
wait a second after D4 white could bring
the other Rook to D1 we have to test
that as well because what I'm noticing
is that after D4 Rook fd1 H5 Quinn H3
Queen B6 A5
if we play Queen B4 then white will drop
the Knight back to A2 and that Knight
will actually be protected by The Rook
so we need to be a little bit more
careful in that case of where we put our
Queen fortunately I think we have the C5
Square so after A5 in that position we
could slide Our Queen up to C5 we're
still hitting the bishop Knight A4 we
can simply take on A4 and then take the
bishop I think that works out last thing
we need to check is why we can't start
with H5 and I think the reason is pretty
simple H5 allows the queen to slide over
to the other side of the board Queen B4
and there if we play D4 we haven't
gained anything after Rook 81 the queen
on B4 is actually better placed than it
is on G4 so that is why I think it is oh
we got it wrong okay a mistake so it
probably is H5 it is indeed H5 and see
this is where a lot of people assume
that you know Grandmasters never get
puzzles wrong or you know my thinking
process is Flawless and not at all like
I would say that my accuracy rate for
this rating range is maybe maybe about
75 percent right so which means I get
you know one puzzle wrong usually out of
every five at least but that's really
where the Learning Happens because if
you got all of them right then what
would really be the point of solving
right why would you need to solve if you
already saw everything to begin with so
obviously here the move is D4 Rook a
rook takes d8 and DC everything is
simple but let's understand why starting
with D4 is wrong hopefully you can see
the screen here I switched Windows yeah
D4 oh it's Bishop G5 that's obvious
right and so the problem was that I
didn't come back to the initial position
and ask myself what the other candidate
moves were I was fixated on refuting
Rook 81 which to my credit I did H5 is
winning I I assess this accurately Queen
H3 Queen B6 is winning for black but I
forgot to come back to the drawing board
and make sure that I didn't miss any
other initial candidate moves longer
variation wrong variation that's the
famous phrase and it's true so often
when you're solving tactics right if
you're making a mistake it's usually not
on move five or six of the line it's
actually on move one so Bishop G5 here
is uh super nasty and if Queen B4 then
we still play D4 what about Rook 81
oh we can play Knight takes C3 F take C3
and this is what I missed Queen to G5
hitting the pawn on G2 and threatening
Checkmate and white can't protect the
Knight and protect against checkmate at
the same time obviously Knight E4 we
just play Bishop take C4 so the Knight
can't intercept The Bishop's contact
with G2 that is actually what I missed
this idea of Knight takes C3 and queen
G5 using the other side of the board and
posing another threat very instructive
so don't forget to look at other
candidate moves especially when we've
spent a long time trying to refute a
particular defense okay
on we go to the other exercise
so so far we've done three this is our
fourth it's black to play and to me just
looking at this position for a couple
moments it seems obvious that there's
going to be some sort of mating pattern
here maybe there's gonna be some way to
win White Queen or promote the C Pawn
but that seems pretty doubtful to me
given that white is up a rook and given
that The Rook is defending the queen so
in in these types of exercises there's
no magical way to approach it you have
to plunge in and get your hands dirty
and start calculating and through the
process of calculation you start
understanding things about the way you
know the mating mechanism sometimes you
get lucky in the first move you consider
is the mating move sometimes you have to
look at it a little bit longer so the
first move that I see is Queen E3 check
the reason I start with this move is
because it's the most forcing it forces
the king to step away to F5 then I'm
noticing that the queen can drop back to
G5 with check driving the king back
toward E4 and I think it's Checkmate
Bishop D5 check King D3 and queen D2 is
made and the reason I saw that quickly
is because I noticed that the C3 Pawn
was anchoring the D2 Square so in my
mind I quickly came up with the idea of
driving the king back toward D3 and
mating it on D2 and that's always a good
thing to do when you're trying to get a
road map in these types of positions is
understand what square is your pawns are
anchoring so the H Pawn is anchoring the
G5 square and the C Pawn is anchoring
the D2 Square both of these squares are
in fact used by the black queen as it
hunts down White's King check check and
myth that was a pretty Elementary one
let's move on and we'll I think managed
to do about seven or eight exercises
we're moving at a good pace so far even
though I've already made one mistake
let's try to keep it at that okay white
to play
so we're down two minor pieces currently
uh but we can recapture one of them
obviously Knight takes H4 doesn't seem
to be the move that gives black a Tempo
that he can use uh to keep the G file
closed so it seems obvious to me the GF
is the move that we should start with
because it's forcing it forces King
takes F7 and there I think we should be
careful not to allow the king to escape
toward the center so I'm pretty quickly
ruling out to check on G6 because it
allows King E7 and it appears that we've
reached a dead end so GF King takes F7
Queen H7 check seems a lot more feasible
to me especially because King F6
obviously gets mated with Rook G6 I
don't even have to calculate further
I'm using my intuition to determine that
that is going to be made I mean the King
has to go up to F5 and there's three
pieces surrounding it we don't have to
waste time calculating a line that we
know is going to result in Checkmate so
after GF King F7 Queen H7 there is of
course the move Knight E8 to G7 opening
up an escape Square on EA those types of
moves are really annoying uh especially
when you know black in this case is up
two minor pieces so they can afford to
give away some of them to keep the king
safe so GF King F7 Queen H7 check Knight
G7 I'm gonna pause there for just a
second and consider the various
candidate moves
thank you
Okay so I'm looking at Rook takes G7
check King E8 Queen takes H5 check
trying to take all of Black's pieces
with check king d8 queen takes Bishop
check already in that position we're up
what are we we're up two pawns and after
King C7 we could tie up the Knight with
95. let's do that again GF King F7 Queen
H7 Knight G7 Rook takes G7 King E8 Queen
takes Pawn check king d8 queen takes
Bishop check
I suppose in that position black could
block with the Knight 90 Knight D7 to F6
and maybe that's a little bit overly
complicated because black will also be
threatening a nest to check on C2 so we
will be up two pawns there but I'm not a
hundred percent convinced that that is
the most convincing solution
so let's look for a second uh to make
sure that we're not missing any more
obvious mating construction so GF King
F7 seems forced Queen H7 seems forced I
mean 95 doesn't seem to do anything so
Queen H7 98 G7 now we could I suppose
take with the queen on G7 but that
doesn't seem to make any sense
what about 95 check in that position oh
that could be promising 95 check Knight
takes E5 Rook takes G7 King E8 Queen
takes H5 but the knight from E5 could
then block the chuck on F7 right so that
almost leads to mate but not quite take
Stakes Queen H7 Knight G7
okay so what else can we come up with
there
well we can play Rook takes G7 check
King E8 and the move that I'm
just about to settle on as Queen takes
H5 check that's what we started with I
think in the resulting position it's
safe to say that white is completely
winning so I'm gonna cheat a little bit
and do what I said I won't do we're
gonna play GF just because by process of
elimination we know for a fact that this
is the move and we essentially know that
Queen H7 is the move let's take a moment
here 95 Trek Knight takes C5 then Queen
H7 that doesn't seem to change anything
yeah it's Gotta Be Queen H7 here we
should pause for a second
so once again 95 Knight takes E5 is what
I was calculating uh for for a bit Rook
takes G7 King E8 but the problem there
is if we take on H5 it's a cool idea
because if Flacco's King d8 then we pick
up the bishop and deliver mate on E7 but
unfortunately the knight from E5 could
block the diagonal check with Knight F7
so Queen G6 check King E7 also makes no
sense
I think we've exhausted all of the
option it has to be Rook takes G7
okay now here we should pause for
another moment Knight E5 once again
Knight takes E5 we've already calculated
that rookie seven not possible because
The Bishop's guarding it now maybe we
can take the bishop with the Knight but
that seems very unlikely because it's
incredibly messy black starts checking
us with Queen C4 and the king is unable
to escape to F3 because the Rook control
so it's Gotta Be Queen H5
good
and I would imagine that it has to be
Queen takes H4
yes it is so that is in fact the
solution and I saw this line pretty
quickly it was the first line that I saw
but if you're kind of frustrated and
saying well why did I spend all this
time looking at Alternatives it that is
where a lot of the learning occurs right
and sometimes you actually do get an
unexpected tactic that results in
Checkmate I knew that this was probably
winning so I knew that this line was in
our pocket if I didn't find anything
else I would simply go for this but
searching for other continuations for
out of the box moves is where a lot of
the pattern recognition is actually
developed and I'm curious what the
computer revalue here is at the in the
final position because after Knight F6
okay it's just plus seven and it's plus
seven because black does have a check on
C2 but it can actually be blocked with
Knight D2 so the best move is Queen F4
aiming for D6 that's a really good move
if Queen C4 check oh King D1 now this is
complicated Kings E1 look at this move
and where whichever way black checks the
White Knight is able to block the Knight
is one of of the most underrated
Defenders because it's able to control
important squares from the first rank or
the second rank that's what it does here
Queen D3 Knight D2 no more checks and
black is mated and same with Queen f191
it's a very instructive way in which
white dodges all of black checks here of
course B3 is straightforward nice
okay on we go to the next one
okay and looking at this for just a
couple moments black is down in exchange
for a pawn but more importantly White's
King seems to be on the crosshairs of
our Queen and potentially of both our
Bishops so taking a moment here to
understand with what sense of urgency
we're operating does white actually have
a threat Queen G8 is not a threat
because after King H6 the bishop on G7
does a great job of controlling
important squares
Queen H4 check is similarly not really a
threat because of Bishop H6 so as we had
stated in the first exercise it's not
that we will only look for Quiet Moves
but a quiet move might be in the cards
because we have the luxury of being able
to afford one unless that quiet move
comes with the bishop on G7 which would
disrupt our ability to potentially
prevent all of these checks so what
comes to mind as possible candidate
moves well I see two checks on the first
drink there's Queen B1 and queen C1 and
the hard part might be uh to might be
for us to distinguish between them that
is a type of exercise that you see often
at higher levels on on chess.com where
you get two similar checks and you have
to spot some sort of minor difference
that often reveals itself only in some
you know on move four or move five of
some variation so again there's no
magical process you just gotta take one
of these moves calculate it and if it
doesn't work you've got to see how the
other check perhaps helps you improve on
that line you can also keep in mind both
placements at once this is a more
advanced form of calculation where
you're essentially in your mind the
queen is kind of toggling between C1 and
B1 that might be a more efficient way of
approaching the calculation without
having to manually calculate both of
these lines so let's take Queen B1 check
I don't know why it just appeals to my
intuition a little bit more so why does
two moves there's Bishop D1 and there's
King E2 so Bishop D1 is I think the more
annoying move because it keeps the king
safe so after Bishop D1 Bishop B3 comes
to mind
so Queen H4 check Bishop H6
now it's important to point out that
Rook h8 check in that position King
takes h8 Queen takes H6 King G8 and
we're able to escape the check so that's
not a problem
so after Queen B1 Bishop D1 Bishop B3
Queen H4 check Bishop H6 it seems like
white has to play Queen to G4 in order
to protect not the king but of course
the bishop on D1
but this is where comparison really
comes in handy if our Queen was on C1 in
that position then with the bishop now
on H6 I think we would be able to take
the pawn on D2 with check and then
eliminate the bishop with a decisive
material advantage on the next move so
let's now transition to Queen C1 check
Bishop D1 Bishop B3 so still no check on
G8 that's ineffective Queen H4 check
Bishop H6
still no Rook h a check and after Queen
G4 we take on D2 and that I think might
be the difference now we still need to
calculate Queen C1 King E2 because
that's not guaranteed Checkmate can we
find an efficient mating net in that
position I think we can Queen C1 King E2
we have Bishop C4 check just going down
the obvious line King E3 Queen E1 check
okay the King has to move up to F4 in a
classical game I would probably stop
calculating there but in the context of
a tactic you often want to try to push
yourself to calculate a little bit
deeper than you would in a real OTB game
or a Blitz game Queen takes F2 check in
that position is Surefire Checkmate King
takes E4 I think we can mate with the
pawn F5 Checkmate and if the king moves
up to G5 then I think Bishop H6 there is
a very pretty mate in one so we can
safely go with Queen C1 check that is
correct Bishop B3 Bishop H6 okay they're
going for rook h8 and our King nicely
escapes the checks on G8 so this is
called the method of comparison where
you have two similar looking candidate
moves and you can calculate them one at
a time but the more advanced method is
essentially like Schrodinger's box right
you keep the queen on both of these
squares at the same time and you go down
the line and at some point the
difference between those moves it might
become very obvious as it did in this
exercise so we're on 30 minutes here
let's see if we can knock out two more
exercises and hopefully we get something
juicy we've gotten some pretty good ones
thus far nothing you know we haven't
gotten any studies yet so nothing crazy
in terms of beauty but definitely a
couple of very instructive exercises and
a mistake that I've learned from so it's
been a successful session thus far okay
so white is down two minor pieces right
black has three minor pieces black is up
two nights to put it more succinctly and
clearly this is going to be an exercise
in which we somehow have to get to
Black's King and there is a bunch of
checks that I'm already seeing off the
top of my head
there's Bishop G5 check there's even
Bishop to B6 check which we're gonna
rule out immediately
immediately because after a takes B6
Queen takes a knight C6 black has three
minor pieces for the rook and were
clearly at a dead end so Bishop B6 is
pretty but pretty obviously ineffective
there's other check there's Queen H4
check but the problem with the checks on
this diagonal is that black and block
get pretty straightforwardly with a pawn
F6
or even 97 but F6 seems to be the big
problem so I don't think the correct
move would be a check on this diagonal
there is also Queen A5 check which seems
like a more serious option so after
Queen A5 Chuck black can also block with
a pawn but there we can play the sort of
thematic Bishop takes B6 check
and if a takes B6 we take with a queen
now King E8 there gets mated in two
moves so the King has to step forward to
E7 but there it's also made into Queen
D6 check king d8 and queen f8 is
Checkmate and I'm you know already from
the very beginning I noticed that the f8
square is undefended that is a good idea
in positions where you're anticipating a
possible check mating combination is to
what I call think in terms of squares
you at the very start even before
calculating take note of the possible
squares on which Checkmate could
conceivably be delivered and you know f8
is one of those squares if the Knight
had been moved away from G8 then The
Rook would have been guarding that
square so let's go back to this line
Queen A5 check because B6 is not the
only move King E8 gets mated in two Rook
takes the eight and queen to d8 so after
Queen A5 we're down to King E7
now at a minimum there I think we could
probably just grab the bishop and we're
threatening a made on d8 I mean I find
it very hard to believe the black has
anything resembling a defense there
it is important that after Queen A5 King
E7 Rook takes C8
um
black does have to move Knight B8 to C6
but the queen has another checkmating
Square on C5 or even Queen A3 in that
position is made in two so that's also
pretty clear clear-cut Queen A5 B6
Bishop takes B6 check black of course
could refrain from taking the bishop but
I don't think that's going to be
effective King E7 the simplest there
might just be Queen C5 check and then we
grab the bishop with check and queen d8
is made so the mate there is is pretty
prosaic and without even calculating the
other candidate moves then there were a
couple more there was Rook takes Bishop
check there was a move like Queen B4
aiming for f8 but it's too slow it
allows the Knight to come out and block
the the access to the mating square if
you're if you've already calculated to
Checkmate then you don't need to waste
time looking at the other Canada moves
if you're confident in your calculation
you can go ahead and make the move Queen
A5 check Bishop takes B6 Queen takes B6
okay they go King E8 Rook takes C8 and
after King E7 Queen d8 is is Checkmate
okay so for our final exercise or maybe
our final two exercises I am going to
set the rating range even a higher I'm
going to set it from 29.50 to 3200 or
let's say 3000 to 3200 let's see if we
can get a really tough one of course
I've got to be careful what I wish for
because I really don't want to make a
second mistake so let's see what we get
and as we get into this exercise what
you'll what you've I'm sure noticed and
you probably already noticed this if you
watched my first puzzle solving video is
that just because the rating of the
puzzle is you know 2 900 or 3000 it
doesn't mean that only a grand master
can solve it in fact some of those
exercises like we got a mate in three
right and you might look at that and say
well that's a very basic exercise why is
it rated 3000 and you know the rating of
the puzzle is relative right it doesn't
mean oh only a 3 000 can solve it it
just is a comparative measure of how
advanced the puzzle is compared to all
of the other puzzles on chess.com and
some Maiden threes can actually be
really hard to spot in a real game
especially if there are other attempting
continuation so take the designation of
a grain of salt salt and I hope that I
haven't lured you into like a clickbaity
video where you were expecting you know
insane exercises and you're getting made
in threes these have been pretty
complicated but my real Point here is
that almost anybody can solve them given
enough dedication you know if you're a
newer player you might have to set these
up on a physical board and move the
pieces around but most of the time you
can follow the logical steps and solve
each of these exercises okay so enough
talk let's knock this one out of the
park
so I'm noticing that white is down in
exchange I'm also noticing that Queen
takes G5 Rook G8 loses the queen so we
can rule that move out immediately and
there's obvious mating patterns related
to the bishop on F6 so if we could get
our Queen to H5 that would be immediate
Checkmate so the moves Queen G4 and
queen F3 come to mind this might be
another sort of comparison type exercise
Queen G4 to me seems more natural
because in response to King G6 we would
have Queen takes G5 with maid on the
next move so does black have a defense
after Queen G4
well again Brute Force right at this
point just brute forcing and looking at
all of Black's legal moves is a
surprisingly effective method so looking
at Black's Queen is Black's Queen have a
way to stop Queen H5 no Black's Queen
doesn't have a single check the Rook on
A8 has no moves The Rook on E8 Rook h8
even that doesn't help Rogue G8 only
hastens the defeat Queen H5 is then
Checkmate I think Queen G4 is just
winning on the spot and perhaps the the
difficulty lies in refute in Queen F3
because King G6 then prolongs the game
Queenie forchek by the way is attempting
move I think for some people but it
actually helps the king hide out on H6
and if you play Queen G4 there then
black can already defend the G5 Pawn
with Rook G8 but Queen E4 check actually
makes no sense if you think in terms of
squares because if you do that then you
should spot the H5 Square immediately as
an entry point to Black's King and once
you spot that Queen G4 to me is the most
natural
natural move okay so this was 3082 that
I admit was a little bit anticlimactic
we should definitely do at least one
more and here we go okay so another
chaotic position a king hunt what's the
material count we are down we're down a
minor piece and some pawns so we're down
a minor piece our own King is in Mortal
danger black is threatening a check on
A3 black is attacking Our Queen so all
of this is essentially telling me that
this is probably going to be uh some
sort of series of checks that is going
to lead to Checkmate or maybe gain of
material
so what what can we come up with here
um and it's important not to get
overwhelmed in these types of positions
you approach them the same that you
would approach any other position with a
wide open King you generate the list of
checks and then you just go through them
one by one and they're often easier to
calculate than it appears having said
all that I'm probably going to make a
mistake so what comes to mind here well
Queen takes Knight check just leads to a
trade of Queens we can rule that out
Knight takes F7 check Bishop takes F7
we can take Black's Queen but then black
is going to take our Queen
and I don't see anything in that
position we're just down two minor
pieces okay so Knight F7
Bishop F7
I don't see any Desperados if we take
the Rook then we lose our Rook with
check that's out of the question
so what other checks come to my 94 check
I think black can just snap that Knight
off the board what about Knight C4 check
night DC4 check
well then if black takes with the queen
then our other Knight captures and we
win the queen with check so Knight DC4
check black can of course take that with
the bishop
okay so in that position both Queens are
hanging
so we could perhaps try to you know
maneuver Our Queen away with check but
we don't have an immediate check because
the black king defends both C6 and C7
and if we give a check on D1 with our
rook in that position the black could
actually take the Rook with a queen and
once again our Queen is going to be lost
so Knight DC4 Bishop takes C4 might also
be a dead end
okay that means we need to go back to
the drawing board are there any
candidate moves that we're missing maybe
there's a quiet move right we shouldn't
rule that out well first I'm looking a
little bit more carefully to see if
there are any checks that I may have
missed let's look at Knight DC4 for Just
Another Second Bishop takes C4 in that
position are there any hidden checks
Rook F6 doesn't make sense okay when we
looked at
I don't think so
okay so we go back to the initial
position there's also Knight E4 check
but we've been there before just Queen
takes E4 I don't see what we gain so
that means it's time to think in silence
for a little while give me 30 seconds
I'm gonna try to focus and figure out
what I'm missing here
this is the fun part this is where you
get to watch me suffer
because normally the roles are reversed
in the speedrun games
okay I've spotted one move that I need
to look at
but I'm pretty pessimistic about it
which is Knight E to C4 check right both
Knights can move into C4 but neither one
of those moves seems to do all that much
the king can just drop back to D7 but
then there's Knight B6 shook so wait a
second that let's set that aside for a
second that's one candidate move that
I've come up with so far I'm gonna look
at this for a little while longer and
see if I can come up with any others
aha I think I might have gotten it
and I think this is the logical
continuation just that if you've ruled
out all the checks then you move on to
the captures
right and I think there is a capture
that I I saw this move initially and I
ruled it out because white is down a
minor minor piece to start the exercise
so you wouldn't really think that you're
able to win enough material to justify
some sort of trade and yet I think
that's exactly why this exercise is
difficult so Knight E to C4 check I
think fails for a variety of reasons the
Ken can drop back to D7 uh and I don't
see a follow-up in that position now the
capture that caught my eye suddenly was
Rook takes Bishop because it does defend
against Black's threat right Queen A3
check there is no longer a possibility
but the other thing it does is it opens
up the secondary possibility of Knight
takes F7 check which would potentially
if the Smoke Clears trap The Rook in the
corner so after Rook takes A2 I actually
think the line is pretty simple if black
takes the queen then we first take on F7
with check
remember the bishop is gone in that line
the King has to move we recapture
Black's Queen at that point material is
equal but the rook in the corner is
trapped and black is at the very least
going to be down in exchange and
probably even a row because I don't see
a way for black in the resulting
position to trap the knight in the
corner
so after Rook takes A2 if black plays
Queen takes A2 then we can capture the
Knight with Chuck and we hunt the black
king down King takes E5 again that's not
really a line you even really need to
calculate with the king in the center
like that surrounded by three pieces
there is going to be a Checkmate I think
Knight C4 check probably does the trick
Knight F3 check both of those moves I'm
pretty sure will lead to forced mate
and so after Rook takes A2 Queen takes
A2 Queen takes Knight King E7 also
there's the obvious Queen takes C7 check
and at the very least we can pick up the
rook and be up a minor piece and we're
mating the black king
so I think Rook takes A2 is a hidden
capture that does the trick Knight takes
E5 we also need to check Rook takes A2
Knight takes E5
because if we blindly take the queen
then black takes Our Queen and black is
up a minor piece but after Rook takes A2
Knight takes C5
at that point there is a host of other
checks that we can now give in
particular I'm looking at 94 check
the idea is to force Black's King onto
E7 so that we can move our Queen away
with check so that in turn we could take
Black's Queen and not have to lose our
own so Rook takes A2 Knight takes E5
Knight E4 check if King E6 then we can
maybe give a
I don't know a follow-up check on C5
that looks pretty overwhelming too
and that's a line that we could trust
intuitively is going to be winning
let's go for it Rook takes A2 okay Rook
takes B7 Knight takes F7 and we pause
here for a second just to make sure
order of operations we take the queen
First We Take the rook and that was a
3141 puzzle that was a difficult one
because of the amount of candidate moves
that we had to sort through but again I
think you're able to see that that was
an eminently solvable exercise it's just
that well the tempting move to me was
definitely night DC4 check because
that's one of those moves you look at it
and yeah that's got to be the solution
you know it's a Desperado sack and
you're opening up an attack on the queen
but you have to think concretely and if
you calculate concretely then you're
able in most cases to eliminate these
tempting moves which often stand in the
way of the solution Rook takes A2 is
really a sexy move it's not a check and
your brain might be screaming that the
move absolutely has to be a check it
never has to be a check and you always
have to look at the other tactical moves
in particular captures and threats right
that's the the con common wisdom checks
captures and threats and it applies uh
in super Advanced puzzles as well
okay we're up to 45 minutes folks so
we're already over the length of the
video that I had intended I think we
managed to get through about 10
exercises some of them were quite a bit
easier than the ones that we got in the
first iteration of the video but
nonetheless right this is the realistic
sample size of what you get at the
higher levels of chess.com's tactics
server
um I hope you enjoyed the video we
didn't have to set any puzzles up on
chess base I hope you were able to
follow the variations I know that there
was a lot of calculation and again right
if you're newer to chess and you weren't
able to follow some of these lines
that's okay uh you know acquiring the
ability to visualize long lines is a
long process and a laborious process
that you have to keep keep at it we made
one mistake in which I got excited by
the progress that we made refuting a
particular defense and I forgot to go
back to the initial position and check
to see if the opponent had any other
possible defenses and I missed you know
a pretty embarrassingly simple people
defensive resource with Bishop G5 got
the move order of two important moves
wrong very instructive mistake and on
that note folks we are going to end the
video I will definitely be putting out
more puzzle solving videos in the next
couple of weeks because I know that they
are well received hope you enjoyed happy
puzzle solving and I will see you in the
next video bye
[Music]